You know, I've been using this phrase.
This is not a rehearsal.
This is the real thing.
And I've used it so much in a sense that it's
become a meme.
Well, it's also beautifully accurate to describe
what it is that is going on right now in all
aspects in the lead up to this November of
2020 election.
Our suspicions about the improper purging
of voter rolls in Georgia have been confirmed,
as we have now received news that, yes, the
state of Georgia removed nearly 200000 people
from the voter rolls by wrongly concluding
that they either moved and didn't just update
their voter registration or for other reasons,
no longer needed to be on the active voter
list.
This is exactly what we believed was going
on in Georgia.
This is exactly what we believe is now going
on in Wisconsin, Pennsylvania.
Notice these are all important states.
It's not happening in Idaho, which is going
to go to Trump for sure.
It's not happening in Massachusetts, which
is going to go to Biden for sure, at least
not to this degree.
The ACLU of Georgia put out a report about
this, and it has indeed concluded that this
purge was not proper and it was a way to just
pull people off of the voter rolls.
Now, the Georgia secretary of state has said
that the removals were no such purge.
Everything is fine.
This was just routine maintenance on voting
lists.
And what they claim they did was simply remove
inactive voters, because this is a provision
that the state has where on some period, some
rolling basis, they go through and apply a
logic for what is now an inactive voter.
Now, what deemed someone an inactive voter,
if they hadn't voted for three years, I'm
sorry, if they had not voted in two general
elections and haven't had contact with the
board of elections during that time.
And if that situation lasted for at least
three years, that is a very low bar to deem
someone as inactive.
Two election cycles where you might not vote
really is not a sign that you should be removed
from the voter rolls.
This is really the wrong conversation because
in many countries, this entire concept of
being registered to vote is a lunatic concept
here registered to vote.
You're a citizen and you can vote and you
don't need any preregistration.
This is not a restaurant reservation where,
listen, not everybody goes to eat at a restaurant.
So if you want of table, you've got to call
ahead.
This is voting.
My friends.
And about three hundred and thirteen thousand
voters in total were removed.
That's about four percent of the voters in
Georgia.
And before that, at some interim period, 22000
were re added to the voter rolls through December
of 2021 because of a lawsuit.
But again, this is just a fraction of the
total voters that are removed.
Now, you might also remember that Brian Kemp
was secretary of state of Georgia when this
was done and he was also running for governor,
which he ultimately won by only 54000 votes
against Stacey Abrams.
So you don't have to look too far to find
red flags in this election.
The guy saying we should pull hundreds of
thousands of people off of the voter rolls.
Not only was the guy running the election,
but he was one of the people running in the
election.
So do not be surprised when this happens again
across the country in November.
And I wish I had some grand solution to this.
Well, we're going to ACLU is going to take.
The ACLU is going to try.
Other voting groups are going to try.
Greg Palace is working on this issue.
But at this point, we've got eight weeks to
go.
We have it is September 3rd.
The election is on November 3rd.
That's, what, 61 days, I think 30 in December.
I'm sorry, 30 in September.
Gets us to October 3rd and then 31 in October.
Gets us to November.
I think it's 61 days.
We need to outnumber them in extreme numbers.
Check if you are registered to vote.
Figure out where you vote.
Find out if there's early voting.
Figure out how to request an absentee ballot.
So we're in the description to this YouTube
clip.
We have resources at USA dot gov for confirming
your voter registration status with links
to how to register.
If you have not yet done so.
The deadline's in.
Some states are coming up.
And then we have vote dawg polling place locator
and absentee ballot.
Quests, these are central Web sites.
USA dot gov and vote dot org, which will direct
you to how to obtain the information you need
in your particular state.
They're doing it.
It's been confirmed that they've been doing
it.
They are going to do it.
And later today.
This is unbelievable.
Donald Trump has now suggested that voters
commit the felony of willingly trying to vote
twice to test the system.
I'll talk to you about that later.
But chaos is the word that summarizes
all
of this.